now people often ask me Laura
how do you put up with all these
liberals who come on your show because
they're vicious and they're intolerant
and yes they're so rude in the age of
Trump and I say well yeah that's true
far too many of our Democrat friends
have kind of driven off the deep end
they spend their days gnashing their
teeth and spitting bile into a headwind
every day sinking further into a pit of
political psychosis they're obsessed
with Trump they're muttering about
muller
Don junior Russia and Bill Barr I'm
recommending that we impeach Attorney
General bar but I'm ready to do so a
person having obstructed the Justice
Department investigation now obstructing
Congress does add weight to impeachment
if the subpoena is issued and you're
told you must testify we will back that
up and we will use any and all power in
our command
whether it's fines whether it's possible
incarceration if only they spent as much
time thinking about why the country
elected Trump in the first place or
maybe heaven forbid pushing policies
that actually appeal to working-class
Americans maybe then they wouldn't be so
angry or maybe they wouldn't be seeing
their 2020 darlings scrambling for
relevance already needing to reinvent
themselves would you say those are
mistakes being on the cover of Vanity
Fair but yeah yeah I think it reinforces
that that perception of privilege and
that headline that said I was I was born
to be in this no one is born to be
President of the United States of
America least of all me profound for a
while though Democrats were actually
bullish really bullish on 2020 member
after the midterms they were convinced
that President Trump was destined for I
don't know Jimmy Carter or HW Bush
territory in other words the island of
one-term president Republicans lost
women minorities and suburban voters
across the country that should worry
every Republican candidate in 2020 and
president Trump if he's going to get
reelected he has some work to
president who lost the popular vote saw
his party's national base shrink last
night not grow that's not good going
into 2012 I think it's a big warning
some big red flag for 2021 well that was
then and this is now spent five minutes
on social media and you can read
comments by liberals and others and
you're gonna discover that they're not
so sure any longer they see a strong
economy and Trump steady or growing
approval numbers and they feel let down
by the Muller report and they're
dissatisfied with their own party
leadership they're unsure where to turn
now more citizens today feel confident
and optimistic about the future which of
course puts Democrats in an election
year box how many of you feel confident
today that a Democrat will win in 2020
hmm of course few policies the few
policies the Democrats have actually
floated have flopped the green New Deal
is a mean new tax and medicare for all
it's just another fantasy freebie when
none of that seems to actually excite
folks well Democrats just do the lazy
and easy thing they return to the Red
Scare efforts will accelerate going
forward into 2020 that Russia will play
a role again they'll try to put their
thumb on the scale again we're gonna
protect the ballot box in 2020 from
another attack the public should know
and that the nation's leaders should
know who worked with the Russians we
have another presidential election
coming up and this president has every
reason not to protect that election
well rambling Joe Biden always late to
the game he was playing catch up to
those guys today up in New Hampshire
he's an illegitimate president in my
mind my biggest fear is that he's gonna
do it again with the help of lad his
best pal and we're gonna be stuck for
six more years of this guy and that is
terrifying you're absolutely right and
now they have an investigation of the
investigators who are investigating
whether or not Vladimir Putin and the
Russians engaged in trying to affect our
life give me a break gosh almighty now
let me remind you that was Biden at his
sharpest around lunchtime and that's
their frontrunner
no wonder Trump seemed giddy today I'm
looking at the competition you sort of
dream about competition like that but
who knows 350 million people and that's
the best we can do I don't think so
even as Democrats I could pick better
than that yeah he could have been a
stand-up comedian I'm sorry move over
Don Rickles he's just so funny politics
without Trump someday is gonna be really
boring again alright if a Democrat wins
you are not going to hear one peep about
election interference ever again ever
again but if the Doomsday's
Aereo comes to pass for Democrats Trump
wins well they have to blame Russia now
or fake news or something anything for
that victory and this strategy by the
way is also supported by social media
Giants right now by things like Facebook
that are systematically D platforming
conservative voices so the plan is to
deal Ajith Imai xeni institution or any
individual that gets in the way of
defeating Trump in 2020 but in the end
however Democrats I think are making a
big mistake
think about this after using the deep
state to spy on Trump's campaign then
the Muller probe all the subpoenas and
the new threats of subpoenas threats of
impeachment what have they really
achieved bara is taking it seriously and
we're now learning that he's tapped this
top federal prosecutor in Connecticut
he's going to get to the bottom of this
John Durham was such a brilliant choice
by Bill Barr John Durham has a very good
reputation to look at high-level high
profile abuses if I were the Democrats I
would be quite worried oops
so what did they get they get John
Durham we finally have a serious man
doing a serious probe of real government
corruption and last night we learned
that bar as part of this investigation
is also coordinating with the CIA and
the DNI and they won't need a phony
dossier or a paid informant or two or
three to give them the information they
need to get to the truth this time and
that's the angle